so Biden made a bad deal for Brittany
Greiner this is a Bloomberg story not
fox in exchange for WMA star Brittany
Greiner the U.S agreed to Pardon Victor
bout a convicted arms dealer serving a
25-year sentence in Illinois but was
responsible for supplying weapons to
Rogues and terrorists under around the
world uh many committed to killing
Americans from the Taliban to Colombians
leftist farc Rebels to former Libyan for
dictator uh Muhammad Gaddafi he's
believed to have links to the Russian
intelligence apparatus and to members of
President Vladimir Putin's Inner Circle
given the intense public interest and
greiner's kiss Biden had considerable
motivation to make a deal yet unbalanced
the U.S got the worst of it bouts
conviction in 2011 came after years of
painstaking effort by U.S intelligence
diplomatic and law enforcement agencies
exchanging such a dangerous criminal
foreign athlete with no discernible
intelligence value to Russia is
unavoidably and affront to the U.S
justice system Tom yeah on the surface
this is like a you know a very populous
move here but there's a couple other
Americans that are over there that you
know are over there for your very minor
things are being held what was really
interesting to me is the White House is
in the middle of a little crisis on this
you know they knew and they've been
planning for weeks the marriage equality
Act and the big signing ceremony and the
rainbow lights are on the White House
you saw that a day ago big deal very big
deal
um you know LBGTQ people celebrating
that and everything but the truth was
and this just came out it's kind of kind
of shocking
when Biden was getting ready to sign the
marriage equality act and he was
negotiating with Russia he thought he
was getting Grindr back
yourself
you're so funny so he was he was getting
ready for the big Cycles when Tom's
being a comedian you've been spending a
little too much time with Vinnie oh my
God that's hilarious
but but did you see what uh Sheila
Jackson from Texas said she goes let me
say there's no one uh that I can't
remember she goes but actually no
Americans were killed how the hell do
you know no no no I want you to read the
whole quote with the straight face
Vinnie okay read it wait uh let me say
this no one knows the story of the
weapons dealer if you will and as the
facts would tell them he would send this
to 25 years he served 11 and 16. I can't
remember the exact number but in
actuality and she doesn't even know the
number uh his weapons might have been
used to kill Americans but he has not
killed America might have but has not
yeah dude this is so stupid I'm not
saying he's not a nasty bad guy but I
would say that I believe that Americans
should know that the sovereignty of the
nation will always be behind them will
never be forgotten Brittany grinder
deserves a fight that we put forth so
does Paul but so does who Paul Whelan
who's the first Marine that's been there
for who is still there you're gonna be
there for another what five years but
it's like it's unbelievable I'm talking
right now athletes I mean her
re-election is going to contain sound
bites from this 20 years 100 and by the
way this is this is uh you by the way if
if so let's flip this okay say DeSantis
or Trump were president yes okay
what would they have and how long would
it have taken for grinder to come here
and what would they have gotten in
return in the negotiations well patch is
really fast either one of them are the
centers or Trump but but uh this is you
want to talk about crazy funny bringing
it up Trump they offered him uh he had a
chance to take a Wheeling out for this
for Victor about and he said no that's
how bad this Victor bout is that Trump
was like listen Wheeling stay in there
for longer because we're not giving this
guy up that's how dude The Merchant of
death like mind you uh I have a friend
that's dog's name is pickles you know
why the dog eats pickles what the hell
do you think The Merchant of death does
he sells death so she's an idiot whoever
the hell she is but bro you can't you
can't compare the two and it's like
Trump that's how bad this guy is that
Trump said to in the wheel and family
I'm sorry God bless him he's a Marine
God bless his service and it's his
whatever but I'm not giving this guy I'm
not giving him up you don't think he
looks like a guy that's maybe like from
what does he look like Rob that mustache
is legit he might have a gun in the
mustache his eyes you know what his eyes
look like yeah say something I have a
problem even if you have a bad thought
good luck yeah do that he looks like
he's like you have a problem that's that
guy dude think about how many people
he's armed from the African Civil Wars
and all that bro that guy is he's done
he's done enough dirt to he has so much
blood in his hands and we just gave him
back imagine a party they threw for that
and you look at how long it took to get
him you read the story about how long
they they worked to isolate him and then
how much evidence they had and how hard
then was it to last on oh my God and the
effort that was spent in the
international specifically the U.S
intelligence Community to arrest this
guy in the first place oh did you see
those um those old interviews that they
were showing on uh social media of I
think it was like 60 Minutes or they're
interviewing the the uh intelligence
American intelligence agencies about who
this guy really was and they're like he
is a evil disgusting despicable man
we're lucky we got him I want to get
back to Pat's question what do you think
the Santa sir Trump or someone else
would have done with enough with enough
time
um let me tell you
the U.S hostages came home from Iran
right after the Reagan inauguration like
it was quick and there's a simple reason
for that they did not want to negotiate
or screw with Ronald Reagan and you have
to come from a strong place that says
listen these are not political prisoners
these are not spies these two folks are
coming home and are coming home quick
and I need you to take care of this are
we communicating and that is a position
of strength behind closed doors then
it's like so what do you need to kind of
say face what Harbor do you need I'll
help you out but I'm not giving you your
guy that guy's not coming home but I
will let you save face I will let some
spin come out of this but my folks are
coming home and you're not going to
screw with me that is the way you have
to negotiate with the with these folks
you can't embarrass Putin publicly but
what you can do is you can give him an
out without giving him his asset and you
can get people back you just have to be
strong enough to sit kneecap to kneecap
to do it and have him believe that you
are not screwing around here's my
question what is what is Putin now he's
in Russia is he a free man in Russia I
don't know what's going on he's The
Merchant of death that's our label
number two questions Pat does what is
Russia doing with him I don't think he's
locked up number one number two if he's
not going to go to jail do you not think
he's going to go he's hopeful we're
doing interviews he's done every single
work hey look they've done everything to
give the guy a parade he's doing
interviews yeah he's doing all these
things you see what the did you see what
the uh what the Russian TV channel said
about this no
well you didn't see what the Russian TV
the lady who's talking about the saying
he says she says how the Americans are
idiots for doing this he says Americans
are such idiots because they're trying
to please their liberal voters they
exchanged him for a basketball player
that hates their countries this is a
Russian new Saint if I can find this
clip I think that's the one right there
that's the one how many minutes is that
uh uh uh uh let me see how long is this
that's two minutes or 46 seconds go to
the last 20 seconds
I'd like to take the audio out because
the music
anyways this lady you have to watch his
clip whatever you do watch this clip
because she's talking about voters are
choosing where what was that Rob okay
that's the part it's the last 30 seconds
when she says it go to the last 30
seconds she was about Americans are
choosing the obvious I think uh for us
is one more p piece of good news the
first good news is that has returned
second good news is that a nation
okay
that a nation that spits on its Heroes
to the extent that it considers it
significantly more important to free a
rightfully charged well-known athlete
she didn't suffer because she served her
motherland but because she couldn't live
for 10 hours without hash instead of
freeing the person in prison for two
years wow okay for serving his
motherland wow this says a lot about the
state of the society this says a lot
about the state of society of these
intelligence agencies
watch watch this wow and everything
related to geopolitical confrontation
They're laughing out of here what she
says about America did you just whatever
you just said how we're crazy can I add
one thing yeah
um she's right wow yeah that's a very
powerful statement right here I I think
um
regarding Brittany Greiner I think
her the charges that she was that she
received from Russia were trumped up she
had hash it's like she didn't deserve to
go to jail like in Siberia that's
ridiculous you should know better to
bring food there no it's not trumped up
but he had half she shouldn't have had
hash okay I'm just like to go to jail
for a [ __ ] some little weird
country like California law too cool
that's not my point my point is this yes
it was you know what I love about no it
wasn't Tom here's my point listen for a
change
here's my point do you know what Israel
does with prisoner swaps
do you remember the story what Israel
has done with prisoners tell me there's
a story
um do you know how many for one Israeli
soldier one Israeli soldier he wasn't
the captain of the military he wasn't a
general Soldier he was a soldier is his
uh his name was this is um back in 2011.
you know how many Palestinian prisoners
they swapped for him I don't know if
that number is right it was about a
thousand soldiers for the one guy so
what they're saying in Israel is like if
you serve your country you have a
mandatory to your time to serve if you
serve your country God forbid something
happens to you we are coming together we
are coming to get your ass and that's
why you don't mess with the Mossad
exactly no they they traded a thousand
Palestinians respect prisoners for one
soldier
that's when you fight for your country
that's when you fight for your survival
you say God forbid something happens
they're coming to get me you know you
know and they're gonna exchange a
thousand [ __ ] ballots let me tell you
that's the problem that I have with this
thing we gotta get that Soldier back
American Soldier back person for him I
agree at him Adam is 100 right with this
but you know you know what it does do so
think about like you know how you when
you were in school and you got into
fights with other gangs like your crew
gun to fight with another gang or
whatever crew you would learn a lot
about the level of unity of the other
gank based on how they defended each
other right you know how sometimes you'd
be talking like well I don't like him
anyways he's like you know I know we're
part of the same style he's a freaking
idiot you're like oh [ __ ] this guy's got
no uh uh backing for his own guy
publicly you always 100 defend whoever
is your side always you always defend
who's on your side privately say I think
you were a little bit off on this one
but publicly always defend you know what
Russia's showing motherland is number
one do you know what America is showing
politics is number one goddamn right
that's the one thing about Democrats
Democratic party is above America that
is why the Democratic political party is
losing votes okay because they have
party over America and a lot of people
don't like that they want America over
politics anybody that's your political
party over the country you represents
you got issues so with all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bad toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]